china's financial center has been like
this for nine days
the scenes in shanghai reminiscent of
those two years ago in wuhan where
kovitz 19 was first detected during a
mass testing of its 26 million citizens
which has now concluded officials
reported a surge in local asymptomatic
cases
medical workers from across the country
have been pouring into the metropolis to
help
the success of this mass mobilization
will partly determine when shanghai can
reopen or for how much longer it'll
remain shut
what is clear is that the government is
still not prepared to follow other
countries by living with covet 19 says
one prominent chinese commentator
overall china is the only country in the
world today which still pursues this
zero policy and i think eventually china
will be the winner china is on the
winning side rather than on the losing
side but that policy means separating
children from parents if they test
positive a practice that has raised
anxiety levels among local as well as
expatriate families
[Music]
state medias responding to the
widespread criticism of the practice
this report with a soothing soundtrack
appears to show parents and children
who've tested positive being admitted to
an isolation facility but it's unclear
if that means the policies been scrapped
unlike shanghai people in other parts of
china are marking the ching ming
festival this is when people
traditionally sweep the graves of their
ancestors there is an added poignancy to
the festival here in hong kong because
of course so many people have died from
covet 19. this time a year ago the death
toll stood at just over two hundred
today it stands at more than eight
thousand
adrian brown al jazeera hong kong